hey what's up guys mkbhd here there's
been a lot of talk about fiber recently
not that kind of fiber google fiber so
what exactly is google fiber well to put
it the most basic possibly it is your
internet and if you want some tv from
google right now you're paying one
service provider for your tv service if
you pay for tv in your home and then you
get that signal from that provider and
that's where your box comes in and gets
that signal and displays it on your tv
same thing with your internet you're
paying another service provider most
likely or you might have a whole package
that gives you a generally subsidized
package with your internet your tv and
maybe your phone service google has
decided to get in the game and become
another one of those providers but with
a lot of things you might want to
consider over those other providers so
it's a complete package now i'm going to
work my way up from the bottom here
there are three possible plans plan
number one you pay the 300 installation
fee for google fiber and you get free
unlimited internet for the rest of the
time that you live there five megabits
per second down one megabit per second
up free internet forever
that's it but that's not why you get
google fiber plan number two and this is
where it gets awesome there's no
installation fee for this one and you
pay seventy dollars a month for gigabit
internet and a google fiber router that
can handle this internet i said gigabit
that is 1 000 megabits per second down
and 1 000 megabits per second up
1 000 megabits per second downloads and
1 000 megabits per second upload plan
number three is a small step above plan
number two what we just talked about
because you get all the things we just
mentioned in plan two plus you get
google provided tv which is supposedly
this very very high bandwidth very
good-looking 1080p tv service where you
get a google box and you get a tv remote
the nexus 7. the only problem with this
tv service right now that would prevent
me from wanting to go with plan number
three is the fact that there are a lot
of big channels missing like espn and
hbo but the super high definition hdtv
does sound really awesome but i think if
i was involved with this i would
definitely go with plan number two now
you're probably thinking why aren't you
already involved in this right now why
isn't everyone involved well it's only
available right now in one city in one
country in the world
kansas city
missouri and kansas city kansas it's a
city that lies right on the border
between two states
but i can't help but think how insanely
lucky those people in kansas city are i
mean that's an incredibly low cost of
living city and you get super super fast
google fiber internet right now i'm
thinking and you can agree with me or
disagree with the like button down below
i think i think plan two is the sweet
spot right now i don't think plan three
is going to be the most popular option
because there's not a lot of tv channels
but plan two a thousand megabits down
and especially a thousand megabits up
that's awesome so right now there's a
link in the description below from
google explaining google in kansas city
right now there's not a whole lot of
information about going anywhere outside
of kansas city yet but you can
definitely hit that sign up button and
be another sign up in your city to be
considered to be next on the list for
google fiber i'm hoping that this is
really successful in kansas city so that
this is able to expand all over that
state all over the country and
internationally that would be pretty
awesome pretty sweet actually a thousand
megabits per second raise your hand if
that's faster than your current internet
speeds and high five actually no don't
hit your screen that's probably not a
good idea so if anyone's unfamiliar with
gigabits per second that is not the same
as gigabytes per second one gigabit per
second is about 125
megabytes per second megabytes
gigabits
it's a translation so that's one
gigabyte every eight seconds
that is ridiculous that's 25
huge songs per second you could download
two albums in one second you could
download enough movies to fill a 64 gig
ipad
in nine minutes you could download the
entire contents of a dvd
in less than five minutes if you're a
youtuber you could upload your one
gigabyte video in eight
seconds that's ridiculous either way i
hope you guys enjoyed this video it's a
brief explanation of google fiber and
again i'm really hoping this expands to
far and wide farther than kansas city
now anyway uh and let me know what you
guys think about it in the comments
section down below and i'll be you know
responding to comments as i usually do
down there either way thanks for
watching this video and i will talk to
you guys very soon in the next one peace
[Music]
you